[Music]
when you were a kid growing up did your
parents enjoy you doing voices and
things like that or in the house I think
they liked it and then it would get to a
point where they were like what like
she's got a you know like a mental
problem and I remember like annoying my
mom one time so badly on we were going
to mail a letter and I was like I feel
like it was a la Bamba moment for me and
I was just like like a whole ride and
she was like oh you're the worst and
your mother said you're the worst heels
over um so she I wanted to mail the
letter and I think she just like wanted
me to get out of the car because I was
so annoying and she was like Oh fine do
it and I I took the letter we had like a
big van and I went out in front of the
van and was like you know like in front
of the van and then she was like Jenni
no cuz I started to like bebop into the
street but there was a van coming and
then I lost my patience with her and I
was like fine and I I just looked right
into her face and then I ran right into
the street and got it I got hit by a van
hit by a van yeah you know what should
happen to annoying people I guess that's
that's curious to get hit by a moving
van yeah we will you badly hurt I'll
tell you what Conan I put my butt out
like I saw the van coming and was like
was like put my butt out hoping the van
would be like here we'll but and like
swerve
and the van hit you and and I fell down
and I skinned you know my palms which is
the growth injury so you did nothing the
pavement was
[Music]
[Applause]
I hope you weren't hurt too badly that's
the important thing
yeah your husband let's talk about your
husband your husband is a very creative
guy
yeah constantly trying to create
wherever he goes what is he up to these
days well he is a film and television
director but we also write our Marcel
the shell with shoes on picture books
together yeah and and he animates and
directs those shorts but he became
obsessed with a particular moment that
happens now with with cell phones where
you think you're gonna take a picture
but it's on video
I know exactly what you're talking about
right this happens a lot because people
will say like oh can I get a picture
like sure and then you realize that
they've yeah exactly and it's sort of a
moment of like really like modern
vulnerability that he really glommed
onto and created a short film that is
very irritating to me because what are
you because you he's actually capturing
people who think they're just getting a
picture taken and they're waiting for
the click yes but it doesn't come it
never comes okay and he did this over
the course of like six months okay I
think we haven't I think he does it a
lot to you we have a an excerpt from
that film this is just a quick excerpt
to to give you a taste take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]